we are told this is the graph of
function f fair enough function g is
defined as g of x is equal to f of 2x
what is the graph of g so pause this
video and try to figure that out on your
own
all right now let's work through this
and the way i will think about it i'll
set up a little table here
and i'll have an x column
and then i will have and then i'll have
a actually just input g of x
column and of course g of x is equal to
f of
2x
so when x is and actually let me see
when x is equal to i could pick a point
like x equaling 0.
so g of 0 is going to be f of 2 times 0.
so it's going to be f of 2 times 0 which
is still f of 0 which is going to be
equal to a little bit over 4.
so which is equal to
f of 0.
and so they're going to both have the
same y-intercept but interesting things
are going to happen the further that we
get from the y-axis or as our x
increases in either direction away or as
x gets bigger at either direction from
0. so let's think about what's going to
happen
at x equals 2.
so at x equals 2 g of 2 is going to be
equal to f of 2 times 2
2 times 2 which is equal to f of 4.
and we know what f of 4 is f of 4 is
equal to 0.
so g of 2 is equal to f 4 which is equal
to 0. so notice the corresponding point
is kind of gotten compressed in or
squeezed in or squished in in the
horizontal direction
and so what you see happening at least
on this side of the graph is
everything's happening a little bit
faster your your whatever is happening
at a certain x is now happening at half
of that x so this side of the graph is
going to look something i'll try to draw
a little bit better than that it's going
to look
something
like
like this
like
this everything's happening twice as
fast and what happens when you go in the
negative direction well think about what
g of negative 2 is g of negative 2 is
equal to f of 2 times negative 2
2 times negative 2 which is equal to f
of negative 4 which we see is also equal
to 0. so g of negative 2 is 0. and you
might be thinking why did you pick 2 or
negative 2 well the intuition is that
things are going to be squeezed in and
things are happening twice as fast so
whatever was happening at x equals 4 is
not going to happen at x equals 2.
whatever's happening at x equals
negative 4 is never going to happen at x
equals negative 2. and i saw that we
were at very clear points at x equals
negative 4 and x equals 4 on f so i just
took half of that to pick my x values
right over here
and then so what our graph is going to
look like is something like this
is going to look something like this
it's going to look like it's been
squished in
from the right and the left
now let's do another example
so now they've not only given the graph
of f they've given an expression for it
what is the graph of
g of x which is equal to this business
so pause this video and try to figure
that out
all right the key is to figure out the
relationship between f of x and g of x
and what we can see
the main difference is is instead of an
x here and f of x we have an x over 2.
so everywhere there was an x we have
been replaced with an x over 2. so
another way of thinking about it is
g of x is equal to f of not x but f of x
over
two or another way of thinking about it
g of x is equal to f of one half
x
and then we can do a similar type of
exercise and they've given us some
interesting points the points 2
the point or the point x equals 2 the
point x equals 4 and the point x equals
6. so let's think about this
last time when it was g of x is equal to
2x things were happening twice as fast
now things are going to happen half as
fast and so what i would do let me just
set up a little table here
the interesting x values for me are
the ones that if i take half of them
then i'm going to get one of these
points so actually let me write this
half one half x
and then i can think about what g of x
is equal to f of one half x is going to
be
so i want my one half x to be let's see
it could be 2 4 and 6
2
4 and 6. and why did i pick those again
well it's very clear what values f takes
on at those points
and so
if one half x is two
then x is equal to four if one half x is
four then x is equal to eight if x is
equal to twelve then one half x is six
and so then we could say all right g of
4 is equal to f of
2 which is equal to 0. that's why i
picked 2 4 and 6. it's very easy to
evaluate f of 2 f of 4 and f of 6. it
gave us those points very clearly
so g of eight is going to be equal to g
uh is going to be equal to f of one half
of eight or f of four which is equal to
negative four
and then g of twelve
is equal to f of 6 which is half of 12
which is equal to 0 again so then we can
plot these points and we get a general
sense of the shape of the graph
so let's see g of 4 is equal to
0
g of 8 is equal to negative 4 right over
there and then g of 12 is equal to 0
again
so everything has been stretched out
so
there you go it's been stretched out in
at least in the horizontal direction is
one way to think about it
in the horizontal direction and you can
see
that this point in f corresponds to this
point in g it's gotten twice as far from
the origin because everything is growing
half as fast you input an x you take a
half of it and then you input it into f
and then
this point right over here corresponds
to this point instead of happening at
four this vertex point is now happening
in eight and last but not least
this point right over here corresponds
to this point instead of happening at 6
it's happening at 12. everything is
getting stretched out let's do one more
example
f of x is equal to all of this we have
to be careful there's a cube root over
here and g is a horizontally scaled
version of f
the functions are graphed where f is
solid and g is dashed what is the
equation of g
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right let's do this together and it
looks like they've given us some points
that seem to correspond with each other
to go from f to g it looks like these
corresponding points have been squeezed
in closer to the origin and what we can
see is is that f of
negative 3
f of negative 3 seems to be equal to g
of negative 1.
and f of 6
over here
f of 6
seems to be equal to g of 2
g of 2. or another way to think about it
whatever x you input in g
it looks like that's going to be
equivalent to
3 times that x inputted into f so g of x
is equal to f of 3x and so if you want
to know the equation of g we just
evaluate f of 3x
so f of 3x
is going to be equal to and i could just
actually put an equal sign like this f
of 3x is going to be equal to negative 3
times the cube root of instead of an x
i'll put a 3x right over there 3x plus 2
and then we have plus 1.
and that's it that's what g of x is
equal to it's equal to f of 3x which is
that we substituted this x with a 3x and
we are done